Hey, Marvel fans.
We're here with Amy Pascal.
This is an incredible movie.
What does it feel like to get
this off the ground running?
Look, it's fantastic.
People are out,
people are excited,
people love Spider Man.
It's great.
So Spider Man, talk about
the love of Spider Man.
He's so relatable.
What makes Spider Man
so beloved by all?
I think because
Spider Man means
something different to
everyone at different ages
in their life.
When you're a little
kid, it means one thing.
When you're a teenager,
something else.
And when you're a grown
up, something else.
It's a boy who's always
struggling with being good,
and I think we all
understand that.
We were able to bring
the super villains
from previous Spider
Man into this film.
What was that process like?
It was fantastic because of
course I had worked with all
of them on the other
films, and it was really
exciting to bring them back.
Out of your entire
Spider Man journey,
what are you most proud of?
Tonight, of course.
Amy, thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]